PAUL IRISH: Yeah, OK.
So let's start.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about the tools that are
available to identify and
improve some of the things
that we actually saw tonight.
And to start off, I want to kind
of separate some of the
performance ideas into
two separate buckets.
If this works for you guys.
I don't know.
It seems kind of OK.
The user experience of
performance is mostly separate
into things.
Like, give me the damn thing
that I wanted, and now that I
have it, I want to interact
with it really nicely.
So, and give me the damn thing I
wanted it's page load, often
abbreviated as PLT,
page load time.
In here we're talking about
things like the network
waterfall, getting image assets
that are appropriately
sized, non-blocking delivery of
all of our assets, getting
the CSS that we need to render
the top of the page, quickly
and not much else, and
also fonts, can we
see the text quickly.
When we're talking about runtime
performance we'll talk
about, like, I want to interact
with the page, I want
to click a button and see that
response very quickly.
Any sort of transitions,
animations when I'm scrolling,
does it stick to my finger?
Like, I am scrolling with my
finger on the device and it
should just be moving
immediately with things.
What we heard about with memory
leaks and garbage
collection, and also JavaScript
based innovation
like with request
animation frame.
But, to show a little bit more
about this stuff, I kind of
want to take an example.
So we're going to start
off with a demo.
This is a site for a festival
in Canada, and it's the
Canadian National Exhibition.
So we're actually just going
to go over to the site now,
the live site, and we're
going to play around.
I'm actually going to do it
here in Chrome Canary.
OK.
Cool.
So how does this look?
Oh, it's too wide.
OK.
That seems good.
So, Canadian National
Exhibition.
My friend Mike Taylor who works
for Firefox found this
site and he said, I defy you to
find a site that is jankier
in its scroll.
And I was like, I know
of a site, actually.
So like this one, what is it?
Inception explained, is it?
Is this it?
It's really bad.
It is-- so Paul mentioned
parallax sites before.
Parallax sites can get into
trouble really fast, and this
site is so cool, but the frame
rate on this is just so poor.
It's rough.
But let me go back to what
I was talking about.
So Canadian National
Exhibition.
So here we are.
We got some things happening.
We got this [INAUDIBLE]
background, full
bleed in the back.
This header that kind of moves,
scrolls up as I go down.
But let's actually look in the
tools to see what we're
talking about.
All right.
So first thing, I'm just going
to turn off this debug mode I
had on earlier.
And always first thing, go to
Timeline, start recording.
I use Command E and we just
kind of scroll up an down.
OK.
So we're seeing a lot
of activity already.
All right?
A lot of stuff.
We're seeing mostly
purple, right?
I'm scrolling in on this area
just to kind of get a better
zoom, and it looks like Recalc
Style is consuming a lot of
each of these frames.
So, OK.
Recalc Style.
Some things could be
happening, I'm
not really sure what.
So we hover on the item and we
can see the JavaScript call
stack is associated with us.
So the last thing that happened
was here inside
Remove Class inside jQuery.
OK.
So I'm going to click that
just to find out
what exactly it was.
We're minified here.
OK.
We'll pretty print down
at the bottom.
Looks good.
Now I'm going to come back and
just repeat that click again.
OK.
Cool.
So now we repeat the click
and it brings me
to the exact place.
I really like it when the cursor
does it's pretty thing.
So it brings me right to the
class name assignment.
So there's a setting in the
class name on an element, and
that is what triggered
the recalc style.
OK.
That's good to know.
Now let's find out why
that happened.
We look down into
the user code.
And so here we go
inside CNE.js.
Let me try clicking
that once again.
Line 33, ah, ooh, ah.
Remember how Paul might have
mentioned do as little as you
can inside your scroll
handlers?
So inside their scroll handler
they get the height of the
window, the scroll top, they do
a little bit of math, and
then they toggle some classes
on the HTML element in every
single scroll.
Toggle, toggle, toggle,
toggle.
Not great.
Certainly not great.
But we can make this better.
So I'm going to--
so the best way to do this
is-- you can see it's a
conditional toggleClass,
right?
You're using the second argument
inside jQuery's
toggleClass.
They conditionally change
it depending on that
math working out.
So that's OK.
So, ideally, you set this in an
F block, and you only touch
the DOM if you satisfy
that requirement.
That makes a bit more sense.
We could actually change things
a little bit, so I'm
just going to edit the
JavaScript right here.
Oh, oh, one sec.
This is OK.
All right.
I'm going to edit the JavaScript
right here so I'm
just going to back space--
oh, come on.
All right.
Cool.
And we're just going to get the
DOM element itself, and
then we're going to use the
classList from HML5.
And turns out, classList toggle
actually has the exact
same method signature as
jQuery's toggleClass.
And now I'm just going to hit
Command S and Chrome is just
going to update that function
on the fly.
Which is pretty cool.
So then we're going to go back
to Timeline and I'll start
recording again and
repeat my action.
Yeah.
Nice.
Pretty sweet.
So here we are.
We do not have massive recalc
style anymore, but we do have
some green paint going on.
Hmmm.
Now, on this device, I am still
hitting mostly 60 FPS so
that's kind of OK.
But on mobile devices I
certainly would not be.
I want to see if I
can do anything
about this paint first.
So, first things first, I'm
going to come over into the
Settings and turn on Show
Paint Rectangles.
And usually, when I do this,
I like to turn on the Show
Composited Layer Borders
at the same time.
Kind of go hand in hand.
So, bring DevTools down a little
bit and now I'm just
going to scroll up and down.
So my paint recs are in a red,
and we're seeing things.
A lot going on, but I can
definitely see up top, this
section, the header is
just in red non-stop.
Now, the reason why is because
the header is position fixed,
and the content is moving
beneath it.
But that is--
that's not going to work.
So it's basically repainting
this, even
though it really shouldn't.
It knows what that looks
like, right?
So the trick here is what?
What's the fix for this fixed
position element?
AUDIENCE: Translate(Z)?
PAUL IRISH: Ooooh, yeah!
Translate(Z).
There it is.
I'm like, I'm excited to
type it and then I
also, like, dread it.
It's like a combination
of things, really.
OK, OK.
Webkit-transform translate(Z).
Oh, my friend.
Some people do like the 3D
version, but then you have to
do zero, comma, zero, comma.
This is my favorite.
All right.
So I got that in, I promoted the
layer and, in fact, there
is now this little gold
border around the top.
And let's see if I can--
if I just toggle this you can
see that gold border coming on
and off because that
is now a layer.
All right.
So we're going to
put it back on.
And if I scroll up here--
oh, cool, yeah.
We do not paint that.
But then we get about
here and it moves,
and we see that paint.
And actually, let's fix this.
So the movement is here--
top-- we just move the top.
Now what's probably a better way
of moving this top other
than just changing position
absolute?
If we want to move an element?
AUDIENCE: Translate.
PAUL IRISH: Translate.
Yeah, sounds good.
Let's do a transform
translate.
All right.
So WebKit and--
well, WebKit and Blink still
have prefixed transform, so we
will do that.
Hop over here and do
a Translate(Y).
And that seems to work.
And since I have a CSS
transition down here, I should
probably update that.
Ah, OK.
Now that's a bit nicer.
I still do see red.
Hmmm.
Let's see if-- ah, yes.
Is that right?
You know--
ahh, oooh, ahh.
And it feels--
I don't if it feels smoother
to you, but it
feels smoother to me.
It feels good.
All right.
So that's pretty good.
And let's take a look over
in the Timeline.
All right.
Cool.
So, in general, in the
middle, we got, like,
nothing going on.
We got a little bit of paint up
when I'm going between the
top or when a new image
is coming in.
That's pretty good.
So that's a little bit of things
that we can do inside
the DevTools.
I actually made a video showing
kind of taking this
all the way.
The background has a fixed
position and we can actually
move that to the body element
and get some wins there.
But I'm going to come back
to my slides first.
Slides first.
Oh, yeah.
All right.
So I want to walk through some
of those operations that we
are seeing.
Recalc Style.
So what's happening inside
recalc style is it is getting
all the style rules that
affect the page.
This is anything inside a style
sheet, an inline style,
the user agent style sheet.
It's getting all the style
rules, it's bringing them into
an object model, then it takes
all those selectors that you
got hanging around and
matches those against
what's in the DOM.
It says, oh, yeah it is
that one right there.
Yes, uh huh.
The selector matching.
Now, as Paul said, happens
really fast.
Usually in recalc style, the
selector matching takes up
about 10% of the general
purple bar.
Not very much.
Don't worry about it.
Now that it has that mass
against the DOM, it calculates
the computed style for every
single DOM element.
So you know in JavaScript when
you ask for a Get Computed
Style, it's doing that.
But for every CSS property, for
every element, it figures
out how things should look.
Makes sense.
OK.
Moving on to layout.
Layout is the geometry
of the page.
And I want to show kind of one
way to look at layout.
So I'll open up this little
demo right here and--
come on.
Jsbin server is in
the UK isn't it?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
It's like looking at
a loaded spinner.
All right, cool.
So I'm going to click these
buttons like that.
Now, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to hit Switch Layout
and we're going to start
this animation.
Now, if I open up Timeline and
record, you can see that as
that animation's happening,
we're getting a
lot of layout costs.
And that makes sense because
layout is reevaluating the
geometry of the page.
And this sort of animation here
has to figure out this
new text flow, and when the text
flows then we get a new
height for where person
two starts and
person three starts.
And it's a lot of work to figure
out that new geometry.
And it happens every single
frame of that animation.
It's a bit expensive.
Now, the next thing
after layout is
determined, is paint.
We heard a lot about
this from Paul.
Paint hurts a lot on
low-end devices.
Old Android phones with not a
lot of hardware have a tough
time updating anything when it
requires paint on every frame.
Debugging this with continuous
paint mode is probably one of
the best ways to do it.
So I'm going to show
that real quickly.
I said real quickly and then
I loaded up a Jsbin URL.
Come on, England.
Come to me, the bits.
All right.
Handy trick.
DevTools, at the bottom, you
might like it on the right.
You can just take the bar here
and drag it up to the--
you can also click the button.
Great.
I have a lot of DevTools
extensions and I'm just going
to make excuses.
OK.
You might have noticed inside of
Chrome Canary that I have--
wow.
Let's go back.
So we're here, we're looking at
this page, we have lovely
boxes all over the place.
That's real good.
But we're going to turn on
Continuous Paint mode.
Now, Continuous Paint mode
basically says to Chrome, hey,
I know you know what it looks
like, but I just want you to
tell me what it looks like again
and again and again and
again and again.
So it's just going to repaint
everything that
needs to get painted.
So if I look at Timeline, it
is just doing the same work
over and over again.
But what this allows us to do
is make some changes and see
how it affects that
graph up there.
So right now we're looking at
eight milliseconds or so per
paint of the entire page.
Now we can try some
different things.
So maybe I'm going to
come over here and
toggle the box shadows.
So I turn on box shadows and you
can see pretty quickly--
sorry about that--
paint time dives really,
really high.
So the box shadow is adding
quite a bit to how long it
takes to paint the page.
I also know that there's a
border radius on these boxes.
I can try turning that off,
see if that makes any
difference.
It does make a slight
difference, yeah?
But this gives you an option to
kind of figure out things.
Now, a handy trick when you're
using continues painting mode
is the H key hides
DOM elements.
So you can kind of walk through
you're DOM, hide
things and see what
the effect is.
So maybe you'll hide the header,
kind of get that out
of the way, and kind of bisect
the DOM, figuring out where
your costs are.
This H works all the time.
It's pretty handy.
All right.
So that's Continuous Painting
mode real quick.
I got a question recently, which
is, there's all these
operations inside the
DevTools Timeline.
What is the order that
I should see them in?
And what we're looking at right
here is, basically, it.
So a lot of times you start off
with some JavaScript, it
touches the DOM, it changes
something, then the browser
does have recalculate style, has
to layout the page, has to
paint it and probably composite
some layers.
Ideally this is the flow and
there's only one operation
per, basically, paint.
Paint is the user got
to see something.
When we were talking about
layout thrashing before,
layout thrashing is, oftentimes,
we're doing a
bunch of recalc style and then
layout, and then recalc style,
layout, recalc style, layout.
And the user doesn't
see anything.
There are no paints.
So ideally, you have only
one layout per paint.
So here's a little cheat sheet
for kind of taking action from
what the Timeline
is telling you.
If the Timeline is telling
you, oh, my god, lots of
yellow, there's so much time
being spent inside JavaScript.
I should point out that that
Canadian expo site--
remember when I profiled
it before?
Was there any yellow
at all in it?
No.
There was no JavaScript at all
slowing down that site.
It was all inside the
rendering inside.
But, if you're in a case where
you are in a lot of
JavaScript, you can use
the flame chart.
I'm going to show this
really quickly.
Who has seen the flame--
who has seen or
used the flame chart?
It's good.
It's a powerful thing.
So this is MathJax.
And they're really good
polyfill for MathML.
But I want to check out
how fast it can
render these things.
So I'm going to turn off these,
come down here-- and so
it's actually just rendering
this stuff out, and I can
choose to render it in
SVG or HTML CSS.
Come over to Profiles and I'm
going to collect a JavaScript
CPU profile and record.
Change this.
All right.
Cool.
Now, normally when you come into
the JavaScript profile
you see something like this.
Just go down to the bottom
right there and
select flame chart.
What is going to give you
is a view like this.
And so this is a time based view
of JavaScript execution.
And it progresses from left to
right over time just like you
expect in a timeline.
And in fact, if you want, you
can record on the Timeline and
on the JavaScript profiler
at the same time.
But you see some spikes, you
want to go investigate what's
actually happening, and
so I'll take a look
at the SVG one first.
So we can see there's actually
a good amount of latency,
there's good gaps between
all these flames.
And if you look on Timeline,
there's actually a bunch of
network activity that's
happening
between these things.
So they're making network
requests as they're trying to
pull together things, and
it's a bit inefficient.
Over in this version they don't
have that problem, but
we can identify kind of where
all the function costs are
coming from.
Now, height is just
call stack.
So height is really
not important.
What's important is width
because width is time.
But we're able to see here kind
of what are the functions
that are taking up time.
We also get to understand the
execution code paths here, and
what calls what and how do we
go from start to finish in
this operation.
All right.
So that's if we're spending
a lot of time in script.
If we're spending a lot of time
in layout, dig into the
JavaScript that's
triggering it.
In DevTools Timeline like I
showed before, you'll see a
call stack.
Find out what you're doing in
JavaScript that is forcing the
browser to do a layout.
With paints, find what is
actually being repainted.
Turn on all those paint rects,
turn on the layer borders and
see what's happening.
You might have to promote a
layer using translate(Z) to
get out of a pain storm.
This often happens with fixed
position elements,
but you kind of--
take another look at what
Paul showed you.
You can bisect what are actually
expensive things
happening using Continuous
Paint mode.
And if none of these things
answer your questions, it's
time to dig into about:tracing
which is a really extensive
tool and I'm not going to
touch it right now.
But, to tackle kind of like all
of these operations, and
how they actually map to your
CSS, we should probably take a
look at that.
So, if we take this little block
of CSS, the selector up
there-- that does have to get
matched up to a DOM element--
so the selector will be caught
up in recalc style.
The height effects the geometry
of the box, so that
is mostly captured inside
the cost of layout.
And a text shadow does not
affect any geometry of the
page whatsoever.
It is just a visual
effect, right?
So it will have no
effect whatsoever
inside layout and paint.
Now, this is helpful to know
because if you turn on
Continuous Painting mode, it's
only going to give you numbers
that reflect things that have
an effect on paint.
So you change the height of a
box inside Continuous Paint
mode, not much, really--
you're not going to
get a good result.
But another way to look at this
is that different CSS
properties kind of effect
these different things.
So, like Paul mentioned before,
transform and opacity
are really fast because the
GPU can handle it 100%.
So this happens here.
They do not need to--
if you're touching transform
and opacity--
you do not need to lay
these out, you do not
need to paint them.
A few happen in paint, so this
is box shadow, border radius.
There are visual effects.
Like I said, they don't
affect any geometry.
Outline is also here, because
outline is similar to border
but outline you can change an
outline from one pixel to 100
pixels and everything stays
the same place.
But a lot of things--
a lot of CSS properties
do affect the layout.
Of course, anything that affects
the position of the
boxes, width, margin, border,
absolute positioning, relative
positioning.
These things affect layout.
And actually--
I took a look at all
the CSS properties.
Chrome actually just
recently--
yesterday, I think--
released some numbers around
the popularity of all CSS
properties on the web.
And this is them.
So width is the most popular
CSS property.
Who would have expected that?
But it's interesting to kind of
look at these and identify
kind of what sequence of
operations they force.
And so most actually do effect
the geometry the page, but of
course, opacity, like I
mentioned, does not.
Another cool way to look
at this is animatable.
Lea Verou made this tool and,
hopefully, I can show this
really quickly.
So this is just using keyframe
animations just to change a
single CSS property on a bunch
of different things.
But it's pretty cool to bring
this up and try it out to see
what it actually looks
like inside Timeline.
So, like I said, we'll take
a look at font size.
Font size.
There we go.
So as we animate font size, font
size does cause layout
and we see it right here.
Box shadow, like I mentioned,
does not have any effect on
layout and--
did I lie?
Oooooh, tough Paul.
Let me try one more.
There we go.
That's pretty good.
So we're doing a transform
animation.
It's just staying on the GPU.
We're not going back
to layout.
So this is extremely efficient
when it comes to animations.
So, in transitions there's
a lot of things.
There's four things that a
browser can do really, really
fast and jank-free.
It can scale, can move,
can rotate, can fade.
These translate in CSS
to these guys.
I should point out, you might
need the null transforn hack.
Maybe.
But, if you're doing any
animations, any visual
effects, you want to be doing
them with these operations.
These can be fast.
It can be fast on low-end
hardware, it can be fast on
high-end hardware.
Every other operation is going
to incur layout, or maybe a
good amount of paint.
So it's going to be slower.
Now, when it comes to measuring
we want to know that
these measurements--
these performance enhancements
that we're doing
are good for people.
If we take a look at Twitter,
the load event-- window.load--
fires about midway through
the network waterfall.
And the end of activity
is quite a bit later.
So looking at window.load for
knowing that the page is kind
of done is not going
to work out.
So we need better ways
to identify how
successful are we.
So this is an approach developed
by a guy named Pat
Meenan who runs WebPageTest.
So up at the top we have the
film strip view of loading a
page that's been optimized
two different ways.
And so you could see that the
third way is delivering
content to the user faster
than the other ones.
Down here is a plot of the
percentage of the visual
progress plotting these out.
So you can see here we're
already showing things to the
user, and so that's why
gold is jumping up.
Now, if we want to take this and
turn it into a metric, we
can take the area above that
line and just kind of absorb
it into a figure.
So this is called
the speed index.
It's basically the area above
the curve that accounts for
what the visual progress being
shown to the user.
So this is a nice quantitative
measurement for getting a
successful picture in
front of the user.
Now, in the real world, we want
to be able to identify
things like how as we're
developing a project over
time, are we regressing
performance, are
we improving it?
Adobe Topcoat is a CSS library
that has a really nice
framework set up for
benchmarking.
So they're using a project
called Telemetry that
Chrome works on.
And so this is actually a view
of their button element, and
on the horizontal axis
we just have commits.
And we can actually see for the
mean frame rate, the load
time, and the layout, how
things are progressing.
And so you can actually see
this is a pretty big
regression in load time
of this test case.
And then things actually did
slow down later here as well.
But we're able to track
this over time
which is really powerful.
Another developer took a look
at this and applied this to
Bootstrap over the history of
the project from 1.0 to 3.0.
And so this is just a quick
view of the drop downs
component inside Bootstrap, and
we're looking at the first
paint metric.
First paint is a tricky one
and it's hard to find good
metrics, but I think speed index
is one of the best ones.
Inside Google Analytics there's
a few tools for these.
You're looking at network
activity, you can identify
page load time, domain look
up, page download time.
All these are the exact same as
window.performance.timing,
but since all major browsers
support this, Google Analytics
will report it here.
You could also get these numbers
split up by browser,
by operating system.
So this is just a view
I made of browser
and operating system.
Here you can see Safari on iOS
is considerably slower on page
load time than the rest.
And I think that's mostly
because it's on a mobile
network whereas nearly
all these others
are desktop on Wi-Fi.
SpeedCurve is a really
cool site.
Its still in private beta right
now but it's hoping to
give you a lot more insight
when it comes to the
performance of your
site over time.
And so here is HML5 Rocks--
which I work on--
plotted against Amazon
and TripAdvisor.
You can kind of see that.
But one tool that I really want
to show is WebPageTest
and I'm going to show it with
a site called Retailmenot.
This page I just loaded now.
I'm going to do a shift refresh
because it's so fast.
The developers behind this
worked quite a bit on the page
load time and it really shows,
but what's really cool is
taking a look at what
WebPageTest tells us.
So I ran this just
earlier today.
So we did--
this is Retailmenot assuming
a cable internet connection
inside Chrome.
And so here--
if you've seen WebPageTest
before, it's been
around for a while--
you might know it has waterfalls
and stuff.
It has a lot more than that.
I really encourage you
to take another look.
First thing I'm going to show
is the film strip view.
So over here in the film strip
view we have, just like
before, every 100 milliseconds
we have a snapshot of what the
page looks like.
And you can see at 0.9 seconds
we start to have an actual
page being rendered.
It's really cool, as I
scroll through this
you can see my waterfall.
We're kind of going through my
network waterfall and we're
seeing that correlation.
Now, another really nice thing
is that you can ask
WebPageTest to capture the
DevTools Timeline recording.
And so we can just view
the DevTools Timeline
associated with this.
So I'm just going to
do that right now.
So Chrome DevTools is a web
app, as you know, so we're
just viewing this
as a web app.
And this is the actual recording
that we were looking
at on WebPageTest, and we
can see a lot more.
So we can see, here's the data
coming in, HTML, Google
Analytics causes a layout,
they're asking for an offset
width so you get the
screen size.
Then we come down here and
pretty soon we get a paint.
And so this is that paint.
It's at 818 milliseconds, that's
why we are seeing a
thumbnail right then.
The last thing I'll show is
that it even takes those
numbers from the Timeline and
aggregates them over the load
of the page.
So we can actually see, for that
entire duration that it
was recording, let's summarize
all the time it spend in
layout, in JavaScript,
in paint.
And so we can see here, for that
page load time, where was
the browser spending its time?
So here, we're mostly spending
a lot of time in JavaScript,
to be honest.
But layout does contribute
a little bit to this.
All right.
So WebPageTest, really cool,
had a lot of features
recently, and the nice thing
is that you can take the
difference between multiple
recordings and be able to
track your performance
over time.
If you do want to use
this, the site--
if you use WebPageTest.org--
the site it has to be--
the site you're testing
has to be online--
but you can run a private
instance.
So you can run against
a development
server if you want.
It's all open source.
All right.
So to sum up, few things.
We heard a lot of
numbers tonight.
Under 60 milliseconds is smooth
animation, under 100
milliseconds feels pretty much
instant, under one second,
mmmm, I'm OK with it, over a
millisecond, users are unhappy.
So here are some aggressive,
aggressive but good goals, and
things that we should really
be striving towards.
When it comes to mobile
connectivity, it is hard to
deliver things fast, but
users get really
impatient quite fast.
Shoot to show the content
that's above the
fold in under a second.
One important part of this is
serving the above the fold
content in the first 14
kilobytes of the response.
This includes the CSS that you
need to render everything
that's above the fold, you
can defer the rest of
the CSS later on.
You don't need it just yet.
If I fit it in that first 15--
14 kilobytes, that number
is not totally magic.
It's based off of how TCP
Slow-start works.
It's the first time that you're
really going to get a
considerable amount
of data back.
Maximum of 200 milliseconds
server response time, 60 fps
on scrolling, 60 fps on
transitions, and a speed index
of under 1,000 would
be pretty good.
So aside from reaching those
goals, which are hefty but
good, what can you do?
I think it's hard to kind of
work on-- it seems, talking to
the people that I do, a lot of
people explain that it's hard
to make the case to work
on performance.
You've got to ship features,
you got to get that out the
door, people expect
the end result.
And I think we really need to be
able to make the case that
performance is incredibly
important.
And the best way to do that
is-- you can show them the
numbers from Google and Amazon
and Microsoft, and anyone who
has said that it effects the
bottom line significantly--
but I think most people really
want to see it with their own
site, with their own data.
So find in your own analytics
ways to correlate performance
wins to actual business wins
that they care about.
So maybe the speed index
correlated to conversion rate.
People that are experiencing
your site faster are
performing better.
Make the case to your client
that performance often might
trump their feature request.
That awesome cool feature that
the user will find once they
register for your site probably
won't get to that if
they're waiting 10 seconds
for the site to load.
Set up infrastructure to track
your perfs so you can identify
over the development of project
if you're regressing
performance or if
it's improving.
And, to be honest, there's
some tools available.
I showed some of them tonight,
but I think it's still quite
early in the space and the open
source community could
use a lot more to kind
of help everyone
track this stuff better.
So I encourage you to join a
project or start a new project
to help everyone in this area.
All right.
Thanks, everyone.
Stick around.
We're going to do Q&A
in a little bit.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]